How did we, a food staple among our ancestors for thousands of years,
become a food that is so heavily avoided today?
First, not all wheat is the same.
And if you shop at the grocery store,
you're likely buying products with modern wheat varieties.
Modern wheat came about by intensive conventional breeding,
which drastically altered the wheat from its original
and most primitive form.
During the 20th century,
wheat was bred to be a high yield crop
and to have more of that stretchy gluten for baking purposes.
That stretchy gluten makes big baked goods.
Think Cinnabons,
fluffy biscuits and really soft loaves of bread.
This is what we call Franken wheat.
Franken wheat was also bred to be resistant to round up,
a toxic herbicide that controls weeds
and speeds up harvest time by prematurely drying out the crust.
Life is say is the active ingredient in Round Up
and is a known carcinogen.
Weed to avoid at all cost.
I love to work with eincorn wheat
because it's the most ancient variety and still in its original form.